come on takes a little bit of guts to
tell you want to destroy something
beautiful but but that dennis is the
whole purpose of of this project is the
egg of mentalism i started the browsing
copy project because i'm actually a
collector and books is one of the things
that i'd like to collect there was there
was one time I was at the bookshop
browsing some photography books you know
they were like folded for the pages you
know the ages will be fun so somebody
probably drop drop the book on the floor
so he kind of set me thinking what
happened to the two to this these books
days left on a shelf of people to browse
and then was this to vent alized two to
four people to buy on another part of
the story you know one day I was like
flipping through my books and I realized
like you know there were scribbles and
things on the face of the models kind of
thing and I realized that my daughter
she was using them as some kind of you
know a drawing block and that also
sucked the whole idea of browsing copy
is I you know why why why can we use
this vente lies books as a canvas for
for you know people to express their
creativity so after I collect books from
a couple of our local bookshop I invited
roughly about 20 / designers to take
part in fifty percent looker and fifty
percent from overseas so the reason I
split the percentage is because um so we
can have a sense of comparison and see
what people in other countries are doing
and also giving opportunity through the
designers in Singapore as well I have
some some designer asking me hey you
know is such a nice book I can't bring
myself to destroy I say then don't
destroy it and make it even more
beautiful reverse was you know can do
anything to it as long as it can be
mail back to me used 20 began as a
canvas for you know artist and designer
to give the book a second life so I send
them all the books after a couple of
months you know the book start start to
come in and then for exhibition I wanted
to do something different so I decided
to create a catalogue so the catalog
will have works with the before and
after works from from sears series 1 and
series 2 so the whole idea is to take
these browsing copybooks begin your
catalog and to send it out for people to
browse the project service' life is
growing and there's a lot of opportunity
everywhere which I can use the project
to kind of spread the message wider in
order since young I wasn't you know very
good with regimented stuff you know
designs and freeze is a life they
actually actually no rules and
regulation and so if you asked asked me
if I have a philosophy I would say that
my philosophy will be having no no
philosophy
you